un euro 86 le litre de sans plomb 95
1,099 le litre de gazole ici la
réduction de 18 centièmes est d'ores et
déjà appliquée sur les carburants et
malgré la neige ils étaient déjà
nombreux dès la première heure à vouloir
faire le plein en ce 1er avril c'est
également automatique au niveau de la
pompe
le prix est déjà remise et le pré
affiche est déjà remise et donc nous
pour
informer le consommateur on a ajouté une
mention sur les tickets de caisse et au
client recevra et on a également prévu
de coller sur chaque pont un sticker
dont le design a été fourni par le
gouvernement pour l'informer que cette
réduction est financé par le
contribuable et par le gouvernement
attention certaines stations des
yvelines ne propose pas encore la
réduction elles doivent attendre de
vider leurs cuves pour se
réapprovisionner en carburant moins cher
mais pour d'autres des réductions
supplémentaires s'appliquent comme dans
cette enseigne de la grande distribution
à maurepas qui cumule les remises ont
fait bénéficier à nos clients depuis
trois week-ends de suite une remise de
six euros pour l'achat de 30 litres
d'essence et 30 euros de courses dans le
magasin les clients
affluent du vendredi au samedi et
peuvent bénéficier de cette remise sur
leurs achats dans la semaine qui suit vu
ces derniers mois de plus deux dernières
semaines du taux excessif de l'essence
c'est une très bonne chose mais oui une
fois le gouvernement a pris les choses
en main rapidement j'aurais pu mettre de
l'essence un peu ya là j'ai tapé sur les
nerfs j'ai remis
15 euros avant-hier et puis là je vais
faire le plein du coup aujourd'hui le
coût de la remise de 18 centimes ttc est
évalué pour l'état à 3 milliards d'euros
tous les automobilistes y sont éligibles
particuliers comme professionnels et ce
jusqu'au 31 juillet